hey this you have to see a republican
official who represents orange county
california named don wagner
seriously asked during a hearing whether
covid19 vaccines have a tracking device
in them now i know we see this on
facebook okay
your wacky uncle might be sharing it but
this is not your wacky uncle this is
well maybe it's someone's wacky uncle
this is an actual elected official it is
supervisor don wagner from orange county
representing many many people the
question came at an orange county board
of supervisors meeting
where the prospect of so-called vaccine
passports was being discussed
now we know that don wagner himself has
been vaccinated he tweeted back on april
3rd with a picture of himself
one and done with the johnson johnson
vaccine start to finish was 45 minutes
great job
to everybody and thank you to dr chow
for administering my shot
quick and painless but here is the same
don wagner
apparently asking the same dr chao it
seems
who administered his vaccine about
tracking devices
you have to see it to believe it take a
look um it's
only at the patient's request that's
correct
does it do is there any intention of
tracking
folks nope
is there any in the vaccine we heard
about an injection
of a tracking device is is is that
being done anywhere
in orange county i'm sorry i just have
to compose myself
there's not a vaccine with a tracking
device
embedded in it that i know of exist in
the world
period okay now i have some news for don
wagner that might be shocking to him
if he's worried about being tracked he
is
carrying around a tracking device all
day every day
it is his mobile phone the mobile phone
he carries around in his pocket
probably without a second thought has a
gps tracker
law enforcement if he were accused of a
crime could subpoena
access to his location depending on his
app permissions
apps can get access to his location it's
in his pocket
or sitting on his desk in front of him
as he asks
whether the covet vaccine has a tracking
device in it this is something i think
about every time these guys bring this
up
the technology piece doesn't exist
to do this if you look at that syringe
it just it just doesn't exist but why
would you need to do it and i know
people will say oh but what about the
injected microchips into dogs
or dogs that's a dramatically different
size
and that is not a real-time tracker that
is something you can
scan if a dog shows up you can scan it
for a microchip it'll tell you the
owner's name completely different thing
not equivalent why go through the
trouble
of injecting billions of people globally
with a vaccine in order to track them
when they are already carrying around
gps enable phones
does he use a debit card or a credit
card which leaves a breadcrumb trail of
where he has been
an atm card which says where were you
physically withdrawing cash
does he wear a mask all day as he walks
around in front of hundreds of cctv
cameras and security cameras of various
kinds
my instinct is also that there's kind of
a moral hazard at play which is a funny
one
in insurance there's this idea that the
people insurance companies most
want to insure are the people who don't
really need insurance
the people that really want insurance
and can't afford
not to have it are the risks that many
insurance companies would prefer not to
take on my
instinct here is that the very people
who believe
there's a microchip in the vaccine are
the people doing nothing that would even
be remotely interesting or
worthy of being tracked to begin with
why on earth
does government want to track like my
weird classmate from high school
who posts vaccine tracking conspiracies
to facebook
who works part-time at a garden supply
store and never
otherwise goes anywhere like who cares
where she's going does she think she's
so
important that the government even cares
to know where she is
advertisers want to know in order to
sell her stuff
but she's already giving them that
information by using a smartphone
posting about her likes and dislikes on
facebook and the like by the way i
unfollowed her on facebook
it became completely unbearable but the
point here is
why would the government even want to
track
99.99 of these people to begin with it
is a
sad state of affairs out there and this
guy represents people
if you can imagine that let me know if
you've had encounters with these types
uh find me on twitter
deepakman and tell me tell me how you
dealt with it i'm curious to hear
we have a great program for you today
glad you were with us
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment
is taken out of your checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman